thessaloniki is the second largest city
in greece Romans Byzantines Ottomans and
Greeks have all lived here and they've
all played their part in shaping what
this port town is today for one weekend
of the year the open house event gives
visitors access to buildings that are
usually off-limits architect Renata Duma
was the organizer if I can almost not
they'd never be this year it was all
about the story a building has to tell
we wanted visitors to appreciate that
after I give us after all the beer
garden methods the event was held in
Thessaloniki for the fifth time 85
different buildings were open to the
public thessaloniki central ours to t
leo square is named after the Greek
philosopher and as a nightlife hotspot
many well-to-do residents live here the
architecture bordering the square
combines elements from various eras to
create a striking ensemble
the cello glues were among thessalonikis
wealthiest couples and avid art
collectors they lived on the fourth
floor of this building now the talaga
yan foundation of art after the death of
her husband al Akita lublu continued
collecting art from all over the world
during her lifetime she donated most of
the artworks to the city's Aristotle
University
after her death in 2008 the remaining
artworks went to the foundation this
year was the first time the public was
granted access to the building I met
mrs. tainot glue once about 20 years ago
she never had children she lived for her
work now I'm curious to see it before
you fill another the cello blows were
married in the mid-1950s one of their
wedding gifts was a Rosenthal porcelain
horse the two low blows were close
friends of the family of Jewish
entrepreneurs
the apartments balcony provides a
stunning view of the horseshoe-shaped
aristotelian square the city is renowned
for its vibrant art scene the bents
ahsan khan building used to be an inn or
travelers and their animals could spend
the night today the building hosts art
exhibitions theatre performances
readings and even tango nights actors
teleost Oh goose is its artistic
director to Kendra back up to talk
Darwin way through the building has an
octagon-shaped atrium the room
surrounded giving the building a feeling
of great spaciousness allocated to the
aphorism and it means every room has
equal importance and hence so does every
exhibition space kathakali taken a key
to the code to VTO kamati Perseus is
really the most goods used to be stored
in the basement and the lift is still
intact today meetings are held here next
stop the private apartment in a
modernized do classical building with
Art Nouveau influences its home to
tullys koo borrows a passionate
collector of designer objects
like this yellow plastic chair and this
wooden one by marc newson or this
cardboard chair by frank gehry i think
that people with an interest in interior
design and architecture will appreciate
a visit to the building musical horn
people often think the combination of
old and new elements creates a cold
atmosphere but when they see it for
themselves they'll realize it works
what's not so much on those easy's it
looks at the person is here to get one
here visitors love is eclectic mix of
objects this apartment was a real
surprise from the outside you expect it
to look quite old-fashioned but when you
enter the designer furniture in this
historical building is just amazing for
some guests though one weekend isn't
enough I was glad to get this
opportunity but two days a year are
hardly enough to see everything it would
be great to have this more often next
spring open house Athens will open its
doors to hidden gems in the Greek
capital